we are live welcome to the iron Lords
podcast episode number 36 and it's
another glorious Sunday and we are back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day we
have a very special guest
lots of switch big studio closings
matchmaking sheisty necessity to do to
discuss so we're gonna get right into it
I want to introduce the Lord who I
consider another young phenom in these
YouTube streets and whose content I was
first introduced to by my co-host Lord
addict this Lord always provides high
quality content that is intelligent and
thought-provoking through his opinion
pieces Vee logs twitch dreams Nimbus on
the beats and is an absolute hilarious
follow on anyone's Twitter timeline
introducing the creator and host of the
press star podcast one of the early
pioneers of the switch gang movement in
the multi-platform Lord who has his
finger on the pulse of the gaming
community live from the six my man Lord
press star Kofi how are you doing sir
I'm fine well I was probably like the
craziest intro I've ever heard in my
life
for me that's great we got to show love
your Lord out there what do you see what
you do Lord in your room so at the round
table we got to show you the proper
respect to some big fan of your working
glad to have you
yeah I'm glad to be here um guys I know
that interesting it out man press R Kofi
I'm ready to talk to him absolutely and
of course we have the usual suspects at
the round table
my co-host aka Lord sleep don't know
where yet
my computer is updating give me the
right cheese Rock co-host with the code
bumps my brother from another mother and
the how of the young wolf not me
no longer looks Li not addict how you
doing sir
nothing much all night trying to get
through airplanes ladies get the box
together and of course most technical
gaming Lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single player selfish experience
this week is offline switch profile is
Illuminati Lord sovereign how we doing
morning my Yankees but you know what the
flag hard so hard from the cradle to the
grave you can't wait for the big things
about Major League Baseball how the game
is played they bother me like when the
Yankees are hitting it can't be homerun
a bust
like and this goes for any major the
team your hit X you have to do things to
manufacture runs you got it you got a
bunt you got a hit and run
you got a tangle you got a move runners
over they weren't doing any of that
I mean no it's I mean I just was just
putting the crap out of people like I
subscribing Joe Girardi's philosophy so
like if you look at Aaron Judge I don't
care if he has 50 some home runs
the man should know how to drop the part
like it sags you got it go with it yeah
I mean so I mean so I would say I would
ask you
like noise out cause like I said I
haven't wanted more oh come on but
cousin that's terrible but uh was that
like for my understanding like I was
ahead of schedule like yah yah was
really long Tina's but I thought this
was like way over expectations we ought
to even get that far
in terms of where they should be but you
can't take for granted every time you
get into the postseason because there's
no guarantee you'll get again so you
know I just think there were certain
things to me as young as they are it's
still inexcusable that you score one run
in two games and of course we have the
excess game oh the lord of combat sports
who was a man of his convictions willing
to put it all on the line and demands
nothing less than the premium experience
Oh beloved Lord King how are we doing
sir we're doing fantastic last night you
had Demetrius Andrade versus Fox and it
went to a lackluster well in my opinion
of lackluster workman like 12-round
decision Demetrius I really mess with
you I love your skill set but if you're
gonna start calling out these wolves out
here these lions out here you really
have to step up your game and knock
these news out you gotta give
performances to have you'll name ringing
in these streets and last night brother
off to the left brother oh but I do
watch all your shows it was on HBO last
night tune in all right PD Yankees it
was fun I was I was on I was hoping I
had to my hope flag I was Jesse Jackson
for you guys
gives you title I don't pay your New
York teams are in in the play oh I'm a
I'm watching but okay and of course it
is Lord God you know here spreading that
gaming realness on the ILP now telling
you what you wanna hear or what you need
to hit so before we get into what the
Lord's a plan I want to discuss Lord
Kofi's video game history
his video game views from the 6 that's
which getting movement the creation of
the press thought podcast so look off
let's start from the beginning like what
are the first kind of systems and games
that coming that you had that you bought
like back in Athena got you in a game um
you know just like most people were you
know siblings you know growing up I had
a Sega Genesis in the house had a
signature mouth you know I'm not really
really old not taking shots at some of
y'all but Youngblood so you know my
gaming history don't go back to like
Atari like I know some people like that
but yeah so first conflict she laid eyes
on was the Sega Genesis you know Sonic
or I'll come back to aren't you uh we
can actually say we're blessed that we
didn't start with Tito yeah so that was
a first console I've actually laid eyes
on was the Sega Genesis you know play
with my older brother's game gaming um
always gets used to get slapped funny
now they can't touch me in any game now
so well um the first system that was
purchased for me dedicated system that I
like for me was uh was a gameboy
I remember my dad buying it for me in
New York when I went to visit yeah so
that was like my very first video game
device I liked my parents actually
purchased for me and maybe that's why I
have such a love for handheld game and
you know I mix it it's it exists quick
question or coffee or law recommend in
the chat on how old are you so this is
just young wolf talk I'm 24 24 24 in the
building baby that's what's up wait what
did you go off for next the game boy
obviously growing up I went to friends
houses to play playstation I never owned
a ps1 you know I was an n64 baby you
know oh my god brought that home you
know big fan of n64 had a moth from
Bomberman Super Mario 64 baby Connery's
and classic WCW NWO revenge yeah that's
not the greatest series of all time
yeah revenge revenge my favorite I know
some people like no mercy better revenge
is my thing
I still played that game you know when
um family get-together my brothers in oh
great game then from there on you know
what do we have we got a Dreamcast I
hope too so I grew up playing the
Dreamcast I saw a ball my grass games
then surprisingly I got an xbox OG xbox
you know say first night yeah so I
didn't get a ps2 until like way later
but when the Xbox original Xbox drops we
got that at the Caribbean I was a real
big fan of halo you know halo 2 was
probably my first online game that I
ever played Wow thinking about it now
yeah Fuzion Frenzy all of those games
yes and ever since I you know started
working on my own job I've pretty much
purchased every platform from there
basically Wow that's some crazy history
well you've got like your really
eclectic like you're all over the board
you had the Gameboy and all I thought I
literally would yeah this is like yeah
right
I was used to feel salty not owning like
multiple platforms as a kid you know I
like trust me having the xbox OG xbox
and all your friends had ps2 at the time
was kind of like stuff oh they're
playing like Dragon Ball
you know the Budokai games and [ __ ] we
got like Dragon Ball sagas like playing
that [ __ ] my god so you know good I know
that I know the struggle I know the
struggle so ever since then like I
always had that mentality of like yeah I
just want them all you don't say he been
so nice
saved up bought a ps3 ever since then
I've been gaming on everything that like
pretty much that's was so that's where
you get that that well-roundedness there
you know say yeah but understand all the
platform see it from different
perspectives like you know some people
are like really diehard fans of like the
consoles itself by like I've been just
more interested in you know the software
outside you know he's care about the
guests oh yeah
kofi is one of the only people I know
that could finish
well first off Kofi probably has it all
PC so he got to superior version you're
waiting for the generic version I said
it didn't come out in my world don't
worry about one X definitive edition
right yes
but I gotta justify my purchase I'm
sorry I can't go now
and then when I get my system I'm like
what's next it doesn't matter you ain't
gonna beat that game it's not as bad
like oh it's not over or is like 30
hours by hours in I'm not I'm on like
the stage seven there's only ten stage
look yeah um what's the cause for an
open-world game you know honestly you
can under percent in this game I'm
talking about collecting all the glue
and all the side missions in under 50
hours like but don't lose any of those
defenses because it's gonna increase
another to our feel like I feel like
capturing the bases is actually easier
than defend them to be honest though it
is it is it so you lose like it's
actually cuz they throw a lot of orcs at
you when you're defending like I'm
different levels and [ __ ] is actually
like you me there's a couple of times
where I like I what siege was it well
maybe we'll see you to level 9 I was
actually pretty you know challenges my
actually lost their right what recapture
and it was actually pretty easy I feel
like they throw a less powerful orcs at
you so oh it's it's not the throw less
powerful orcs you you own some of the
orcs if you infiltrate the base and only
face like one or yeah yeah so we go
definitely hit that shadow war talking
with the Lords of plane this will finish
out with the Lord call from self as far
as ohm fuse from the sex are you from
from Canada correct yeah yeah right so
talk to me about like you know saying
like gaming out there like anywhere you
know I just just the price isn't good
for basically you know we're all yeah
basically just games costs more here
that's why I'm actually I'm deaf I'm
glad that I got into PC gaming when I
actually did because you know the prices
are honestly blessing me I don't know I
actually started gaming and gaming on PC
fifteen so I'm pretty relatively new
I've been gaming on PC forever you know
I'm saying
and I'm glad that I got into PC gaming
when I did because some of you guys know
that I buy a lot of games you know like
I play a little weird on a black coffee
buys everything plays everything right
so can you can you imagine you know
gaming on all these consoles paying
$79.99 free every game I know I'll be
broke I can't afford it right I'm
stuffed to do so I'm glad I did get into
PC gaming because the prices are very
very reasonable here you could get a
keys for pretty cheap so adversely now
my question to you because I was
listening to press star and um you got I
think you've mentioned that you guys
don't have like a Best Buy like you have
a best package you don't like a buy the
game is playing you know we don't have
no programs of gamers because I seem
like you got you're so lucky
that's crazy
Wow I don't think so can they go
beautifly
a program like that over here not have
been blessed thank you you're about to
have a program over there I want to get
it to the switc gang move and I brought
it to you because you know I'm new to it
as I've been following on Twitter I've
seen it I don't know who necessarily
originated okay I want to clarify that
what you platform not a hundred percent
I started that whole [ __ ] 1% it's funny
because it was actually like an inside
joke between you know me Erica and you
know black you know I [ __ ] out with
these guys on Twitter game I like we all
just chop it up and stuff it was just it
was like a joke ting like when they
revealed the switch right um right after
the conference I'm like you know who's
down with the switch gang or so she have
a tweet with the day I think it's still
a base look of search and everything
ever seen ever since then like you know
we've been just using it just to talk
[ __ ] you know and just have fun you know
there's nothing it's not that's too
serious like I'm not really you know you
know walking around with a great band
and now you know he didn't do a rock
model hidden dudes over there I might I
might have taken it a little bit too far
making those songs and [ __ ] but I was
just trying to be a very some
entertainment because you know you can
entertain people without doing you know
back and forth internet drama like
Samsung cross-eyed yes or no just making
some fun music videos started off as an
inside joke kind of blew up kind of you
know pretty big that people are using
the term and [ __ ] like that so it's
pretty funny to lots
yo salute the Kofi now I got the
official confirmation that I love I
guess he is nice big data of the switch
gag terminology at the boobies so salute
because I'll be rapping he's a liar I
thought it was the coolest dig everybody
on my island doing it because just like
you more coffee we kind of saw it from
the beginning that it could be a
movement I mean sorry was I finally did
if I actually did turn to something
bigger than it actually was supposed I
think it was probably music videos I did
some [ __ ] then Omega C today like I
always say yeah we need to make a stock
together I'm like I know this one you
know it was all fun and of course the
last thing I would talk to you but no
coffee I was also about the creation of
press star so how did that come about
because I actually liked your team out
there believe was a Jamie your man home
budget moles Erica
Alex like very cool diverse you know I'm
saying cast in panels so like tell me
the whole start a press star how pressed
I started you know I was obviously I was
influenced by you know other people in
the community who have started the park
doing the whole podcast thing cuz you
know you know BG and weapon wheel their
influence I'll give me Jesus shout out
even though shout out the Lord BG no but
you know I just been seen in and I
wanted to create something I've been
like during the idea with my friend Jay
main you know be bouncing back
you never live that down now I have
audio yeah so yeah I was bouncing an
idea you know back and forth of my boy
BG I mean Jay main and you know we're
just talking about like y'all I'm
thinking about setting up a little
podcast so one day I actually you know
did an episode and then started off good
but one thing I noticed that like we
were growing that extremely pretty fast
you know we started off and doing
pressed our podcast you know every two
weeks bi-weekly and just not that long
ago we actually started doing the week
you know mmm and uh his overalls been
pretty good you know like at first I
didn't have a solid cast actually no
that's actually kind of new
I was actually who are on the cast like
Jamie and Jack those guys were there
from day one you know by added Erica and
them Alex a bit later I like I was
always trying to get new people to show
up on the podcast I was like my thing to
get like a lot of different just to show
up nice
definite like what you're doing out
there and like I said I like you kind of
got a nice group everybody's got their
niche everybody got their you know they
kind of feel what they are into is good
people yeah yeah shout out to the press
stop podcast huge fan of the show
so getting to know what the Lord's are
plans just we got a little coffee
nabilla start with him first what have
you been playing this week I finished up
the evil within two great game
definitely recommend it is the true end
in a shadow of war blue box free blue
box for the regular - lots of real money
Fire Emblem warriors that games I like
money because if you said without Lou
boxes at all yeah yeah I use in-game
currency which is yeah um I purchased
Fire Emblem war it started that the game
is met like I was saying it's not that
good but it's I'm not really a big fan
of those games like to be honest like I
just kind of bought it to waste time
until Mario Odyssey drops today yeah
take my switch to work with me every day
I've been actually been you know hopping
back clean Zelda trying to get a hundred
and twenty shrines I'm pretty close I'd
have nine 18 actually 18 more to go then
I have all hundred 20 shrines yeah
something like that without achievements
like you can't you can't catch me dead
dishonesty Gaiman attic like I'm doing
it I'm thinking how great this would be
if it had a team oh that's exactly it
would be 104 you know to switch get into
achievements in the future yes I've been
in
yeah you could white container okay no I
just yeah so I have 18 more strands to
go and I'm done that so I I've been
playing down thinking about picking up
rhyme finishing that up you know before
Mario's dries so that's what I've been
playing cool Lord addict would have you
been playing this week besides shadow of
what blazing I play destiny for two
hours and I played shadow of war for the
other two days okay wow wow that's
what's up I mean you know before I want
to go on a little mini rant
who said this this this stuff about
shadow war you only thought you could
only get legendary orcs through loot
boxes yeah I heard that too
I heard I heard that that's even
clarified because that's not true at all
for takes 30 plus hours like this is
what we get for listen to some of these
media people man act 4 would probably
take 30 plus hours if you suck at it
yeah yeah because if you lose the
defense if you lose every defense siege
you gonna be there for a minute because
you have to retake the castle and that
takes longer than the defence people
that are qualified or reviewing these
games
yeah spreads Internet also just a little
bit of like I said like once the five
storm starts and then it's just a whole
bunch of misinformation
I don't know anything yeah I didn't know
anything about you know what the
specifics were with the loot boxes so I
was watching people's like coffee stein
laugh and people you know that bought
the game and not at it and said like
what's really going on and people like
nice thing so just go to show you how
things can get out of control
misinformation gets spread and then
people taking that as fact the actual
question right um let's say I purchased
this
right and um I get this legendary orc or
whatever you're talking about here right
can I lose him yes
[ __ ] in this game because your
orange can die in combat so I wanna tax
addicts something like you know I've
used it in game currency right cuz
obviously that speeds up the process
right so um I you know how when you
you're in the market and you want to
actually deploy your orc you know what's
kind of [ __ ] like I open I open uh
or basically Luke Ray and I placed them
in like one of the positions right and I
was doing it again but basically like my
whole place is full up right so
basically they kill each other you know
what I'm trying to say yeah yeah
basically so basically the guy that I
just put in there and I was put in
another guy in there and killed the guy
you know say so it's kind of most
imagine paying real money for not to
happen like this can we have loot
insurance I see I think the loot boxes
in that game is pretty pointless
especially you're buying or accession
because they could freaking die and just
wait so I thought they said they were
stronger no they're not stronger they
just legendary it's like I've known
because they give you in-game gold that
your friend is trying once to try it one
yes once and I did notice the time that
I used the in-game gold I got nothing
but legendary spending real money but
you can get a legendary orc from using
the regular one yeah you can't the thing
that's funny is you know it's what I've
said a lot for those that's been in
parties
I mean there's these things called the
pits it's where you pit up an ogre
against an orc against an orc yeah you
got to do it for a variety of things and
the funny thing about it is like when I
got that gold I sent that legendary in
there to infiltrate him until war chief
and he got red and I'm like if I would
have paid money I'd be very mad like
video clip of one of you I think it was
one of your organs they get laid through
put up like a bomb into his stomach and
they blew him up it was crazy like
that's good they were going one-on-one
and one of them had ground and pounded
one and beat him and then he just blew
up a little seemed like they put a
grenade in system questions how often
did you run in the legendary odds oh I
they're not like rare in the game
actually just playing the game normally
you see them all over the place now you
will find out if you if you seek nothing
but legendaries for the siege defenses
that's a different story because like
you know you have six or seven seed
spots so sometimes you'll find yourself
settling with epics and not looking for
it like extra like I think I have like
three to four legend areas on every seed
defense like oh you're a little bit
overrated like let's see I have some
high-power Oryx that are not even
legendary but what you want is you want
someone with enraged everything or
enrage on in injury and you'll win every
fight after that you oh my gosh I know
everybody you know and not like us I'm
in the minority
I do not did not buy to shake some win
if we screw up your version for that
painting you know same kind of
experience but I didn't want to shut it
down because I know you know it's
probably right now and people who are
not buying a next day are buying it so I
want to give that respect you know more
before biting cuphead than any other
game on xbox right now even solve what
have you been playing same thing is last
week very working a lot so very little
destiny I was able to get my crucible
milestone yesterday I just played for a
little while I'm at 300 I'm damn near
three or four now but I happy I can't
set aside time to do a rade I really
want to do the rate Oh get you through
that and beyond that just stuff on
switch more axiom verge and excited for
Mario taking the day off Friday to play
some Mario no doubt looking this week I
started the night for I waited for
Tuesday like everybody else and then we
got to the knife all of the knife for
was the the shadow dude that was
disappearing at the end and did rights
okay so we got it done that day after
yeah bounced out we had got it done
right so the next day I said yo I'm
gonna jump on with the rest of my
characters and knock this stuff out um
and it was switched it wasn't the same
nightfall so I was perplexed I thought I
was in the matrix I really thought it
was a butterfly effect Mandela effect
I'm like I'm no I'm not buggin I know
for sure because I recorded it I know
for sure that I and I went back and I'm
looking I'm like what's going on
well they had a hotfix actually they
said was a lot of bugs in it alright so
this whole week I've been doing
nightfalls every day at least like ten a
day um my clan has so we've been doing
it on prestige I got a way to do it on
prestige and to knock it out with the
five minutes or I'm getting everybody
their Rat King and giving everybody
halos was like you know I'm giving the
Chrysler 80 go boom bang boom bang you
know think that war
it'll run around a towel yeah yeah I've
been doing prestige all we know I wanted
to do the raid but topic yeah we get
into that here so yeah for me it's
pretty much I kind of um when we get
into my tablet you'll understand why
I've kind of cooled a little bit on
destiny this week I got the bag for a
big shout out the reed shout out the
demon we got some other stuff done but
um yeah been really hopping back on my
switch um I want to shout out on you
know dark mediu Wolverine
this is my low low indie game right now
on a switch Oh having so much fun with
these games like hope I don't know if
you ever seen it it's like a like a hack
and slash kind of old-school beat them
up joint
yeah have you seen it yeah so base if
you look on the eShop it's like it's
like $20 and um said name a game is
rollerblading they talked about it on
the other in the indie showcase like not
that long ago but I'm having a good time
with its co-op real brutal so shout out
to them guys over there that made that
game's really really fun game so other
than that yeah just been it kind of
getting ready for Mario get my stuff
together as far as the switches concerns
oh yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be big
so we're gonna get in city some last
poll you know so last week's the alcohol
is in the people have spoken to the
question with games like cuphead Zelda
Dark Souls hell-blade etc are we seeing
a resurgence of Hard difficulty games
becoming popular the winner at 97% in
the most lopsided I hope people ever is
the yes real skills are back group a
whopping three for sale is the no hard
games do not equal good games group so I
want to thank all of those who
participated in that at iron law podcast
with a poll what do the Lord's think
about this I mean hard games don't
necessarily equal a good
it has to be I mean it's things like
Dark Souls and things like cuphead I
mean these these games are developed
their superior games it they excellent
at what they do
so yeah a hard game doesn't necessarily
equate to being a good game um but yeah
man like people III think more
especially with you know with Dark Souls
and now cuphead it's one of those things
where people are more and more willing
to engage with these games like I said
before like when Dark Souls first came
out I kind of didn't mess with it and
then little by little like I got it free
I got it with games of gold and I've
tried out the first dark clothes and I
was like wow I can get into this and I
have blood-borne on the ps4 and it's
like it's a matter of having the
patience and be willing to lose a lot to
get better and to understand and you
will constantly improve but it's just
one of those things like if you don't
have the patience for it it's not it's
gonna turn you off immediately but I
think that's fantastic
it's good to see like I said dumb games
time succeeding and you know bringing
skills back what do you feel Kofi as far
as uh these Hard difficulty games kind
of back in the spotlight um I like him I
like him like cuphead one of the recent
games right a lot of people are having
trouble with that game you know I didn't
realize how you know it you know people
beat that game there's not a lot of
people that speak up it yeah a lot of
people don't have the patience for it
you know basically they're not
progressing they put it down you know
what I'm saying so shout out to kids you
know beat the game yeah you need to get
on that yeah I think there's always
gonna be no hard games around are games
that you know take a lot of skill to
play you know yeah absolutely
you were saying something it's it's okay
I'll let it go to get into you'll get
this thing pop and so on Lord
the MPD's came out so yeah my topic was
initially the Sony Music Entertainment
developing third-party games now but
it's gonna come into play but there's so
much of the stuff that came out so it's
gonna be just a switch topic so yeah
like September
MPD's came out and Nintendo for the
third month in a row has won the
hardware no and we like I some of us
have been saying nay some of us have
been saying yeah but the fact that
matter is that I've always loved a
Nintendo was stockpiling just for this
purpose so to be ready for the end of
the year and it seems that there are
finally more systems in stores and
people are able to purchase and more and
more people are picking up their
switches so it's fantastic to see that
they're that they're winning Hardware
hopefully that carries through to the
end of the year in terms of software
there's something going on with the MPD
though in terms of software like the
actual list isn't out yeah I heard it's
coming why there was I put miscount or
something they're trying to UM get that
straightened out before they put out the
definitive list so to speak so that
Nintendo put out there where they didn't
do it
yeah they placed yeah Mario rabbits did
7th I think a through Samus Returns
birth to the wild in Mario Kart 8 are on
the list also at 10 and 11 so they're
the games that are are are still selling
well there's still something well we
expect that to be up there again with
Mario at the end of next week
so yeah man I mean again is what we were
hoping from a Nintendo the worry was
that they weren't gonna be able to have
the stock ready to go so that people's
excitement to purchase this at the end
of the year would be satiated and so far
so good so we'll see funny thing will be
as if they sell they sell out before
November why this they are go we have
increased their production to like 2
million or some [ __ ] 2 million a month
so and I've already seen pictures of the
Mario bundles in stores I'm sure some
people are breaking Street data on that
because it's supposed to not go on sale
until next week but I'm sure people are
breaking street date on that so the
bundle on that here
I didn't mm-hmm yeah and I'm sure the
mom and pops around if they have it
they're selling it so that's that's
fantastic let's hope they keep it up um
in terms of them yeah I know you hope
now look okay so we give local fee
context um the two of the lords here
both the Lords of split or the round
table so we got a MeetMe answer solve we
believe in tender win November mm PD
yeah we have Lord King in our attic they
go with Xbox one X I'll be actually the
whole Xbox brand because you got yeah as
a razor brain so we've been battling
each other for months Kofi as far as who
you know look I wouldn't I actually
thought you know Nintendo would admit
but wouldn't win um September to be
honest cuz destinies thank you you know
the bundle so I was actually shocked
when I got the PlayStation didn't wins a
tempers because they only had a pro
bundle of denim yes so it's definitely
gonna be interesting times like I really
don't watch MPD too tough but like
obviously with the launch of the Xbox
one the Exile everyone's paying
attention to see you know the interests
basically everyone's trying to gauge the
interest for this um cuz a lot of people
are hyped this console and we want to
see if it wins MPD because if it doesn't
win damn swear they're gonna be lit well
on see I fell on the side down come on
you like our talks about to launch a new
console like how can you
but then again and then again I think
about like you're like that Mario
Odyssey is doing numbers cuz you guys on
no no even Odyssey
we'll only priorities like it past
horizon already on the Amazon like for
like crazy so like the height for that
game is insane we all know that a tree
for that game is gonna be insane and uh
you know it's tough it's tough Xbox or
switch I don't know I don't even know if
PlayStation is gonna have a real say let
me ask you let me - with any of the
bundles like the you figure what they
Banco Star Wars what bundles we figure
they might come strong with as far as
games they have knocking are worth
don't they have a call the duty one I
really think I called it the monthly
wins
yeah so it's definitely gonna be
interesting but if aren't you had to
make a bet at first I was like Xbox but
um I'm looking at the hype for Odyssey
I'm thinking you know maybe Nintendo got
this okay okay it is if it's close could
go either way so we reckon on an aisle
or Parker's I so for the record was
saying Lord coffees going switch I think
without rain I be colder right cuz we're
gonna do this thing called the bend the
knee segment right and the bended knees
segment for everybody you're saying with
that with their every D drop that knows
December we're saying who went over I
need y'all back for quick recap sec you
know said it's gonna be cold baby oh no
no no I know I know like every like
every single podcast right now YouTube
that does game in discussions has like a
little bag going on with you know
November MPD that's why it's so
interesting because we just want to see
what the ex is going do man we are being
sold on the podcast saying it's gonna be
Xbox it's sold out but is this sold out
that isn't that doesn't really say
anything to me you know uh-oh
we saw a lot of Scorpio editions like we
don't know the number is we don't know
how
I got me thinkin well got me thinkin
look right now
next box 1s is getting curb-stomped
right you know what I'm sayin okay so
you are you really telling me that
everybody's holding off to get us expert
$500 and it's and it's what's it called
is it $4.99 the states what is it $5.99
here in Canada so I know in the exam are
not out here going crazy over that like
you know I'm thinking maybe Nintendo got
this yeah I'm I'm thinking about this
because now college is my man cuz like
I'll see you like if I get marks off one
like a couple of months you know like
September and then maybe like people are
a you're buying X boxes you don't say
but apparently like um the last & peeta
Xbox one was all the way in 2016 October
or something like that that's what I
heard there's some someone told me down
to Donna I might be wrong on that but I
heard the last time while Microsoft one
MPD was all the way in 2016 that's crazy
so you I don't know I don't know I don't
know if everything Xbox fan is out here
I'm gonna buy X like that I really doubt
it I think a lot people are just talking
on the internet then let me play devil's
advocate Laura coffee because even
though I'm repping the switched getting
for that month let me play that what
about with the combination of the Xbox
1s and let's just say they dropped that
law because we know that's the base
model right
and even Phil Spencer himself I said
that's right that's the one that was
right yeah it's the thing is it ain't
even it's always hidden period no that's
the thing though because I was in a nerd
for like how long now you're right
you know I'm saying so if no one's
buying dumb now like unless they have
some crazy kind of $1.99
deal which you know mark something I'm
very like I wasn't able to look like
five games or some [ __ ] give me that
[ __ ] then I don't know like right now
the switch is hot we all know it we all
know it [ __ ] gonna flop right out the
gate near right now one of the biggest
games dropping so it's very likely it's
obviously a battle I see it about a
between um you know a Nintendo Marcus
really because they got you conjugated
via surprises only forget one day easy
with that beard up yeah would be crazy
I won't watch if an idol I wouldn't put
it past it because let's be real here
they got a Star Wars bundle and a Call
of Duty bundle in November would you
guys be Microsoft got first Saudi got
sec is which got a funny turn out like
you know funny turn out mm-hmm the thing
is like yo there's like what 65 what
millions Playstations soul there's some
[ __ ] like that [ __ ] you know I'm like
damn like slowly kasi I'll come through
and when oh it would be it would be
pretty impressive that we put in my
after just you know coming for
definitive answer and say you'll switch
switch God mob a COPI switch November
and it definitely got it October I think
though that we'll revisit that bended
knee me to get back no dumb loss solve
you were saying about the the rusty
topic is reference to do not the MPD's
of the this the new Sony Music
Entertainment wing this publishing indie
titles okay let me let me just day we
can go into your topic afterwards but
this is the unties label and it again
yeah it does go into your topic because
it's showing Sony's need and willingness
to kind of play nice with someone with
its quote-unquote competitors without
necessarily directly playing nice if you
notice um so this this new label is
gonna be publishing games on PC and
switch and it says other platforms but I
doubt very much those other platforms
include Xbox I don't think that's
happening so um what's interesting about
this is that you know Sony after they
sort of made it clear that they kind of
didn't need Indies anymore probably
realizing that it was
the best PR move so by doing it this way
by Sony Music Entertainment kind of
taking this uh this new publishing wing
instead of Sony proper um they're able
to sort of support third parties and
also support other platforms without
necessarily directly doing it with the
Sony under the quote-unquote Sony banner
I think it's perfect because they're
realizing that the switch is huge for
Indies now I think if you look at Indies
it's becoming sort of the de-facto
platform for it even more than Kensi
because of the portability factor um so
I think it's a smart move for them I and
it ties in to what King is gonna say and
what I've been saying all along that
these Microsoft and Sony need to play
nice with Nintendo it makes sense that
they would mmm that's log King with them
well I know I know you go with that I
don't know I don't know it's good what
are the Lords think about all real quick
about that uh Cole you know deal so to
speak so need what the end of the game
and everybody's infested with worms so
um listen what they're trying to do is
they try to make sure that they cover
their bases and I feel and I would cover
my bases as well if you see somebody hot
over there you're gonna try to associate
yourself in some form of factor by you
know tagging a name is something or
every time you know they're doing
something your name is linked to it so
they understand that these guys is
getting bred out of hand and moving and
they don't have a handheld system in
each street so why not produce games
that can be put on this handheld
portable slash they're not looking at in
the home system they're looking at is
affordable and yeah get our games on it
that are in their portable space let's
make some bread off of these tools but
let's do it in a way that it doesn't say
Sony it says cheap cheapy games and um
people don't understand they're you know
cheap cheapy Estonia now Lord King we
want to just bleed into your topic right
now as far
yeah your host switch switch Vanessa you
got to switch that's been going well
guys I've noticed Nintendo and since
their humbleness from doing the Wii U
you know they got humble bro they really
came in on a high and it was just like
yeah cuz that we had him spoken it was
samokhin in these streets so you know
selling a hundred million come on man
you you think you can't do no wrong
well they did wrong they did wrong they
did terrible actually um and that was
mixed messaging so you know when it came
to the switch it was no mixed messaging
and they purposely positions they self
so they didn't look like direct
competitors to the big two now we're
gonna keep saying the big two and I'm
only talking in terms of power I'm not
talking in terms of stature or legendary
status or whatever I'm just talking
about the terms of power alright so we
know that it can't compare so once they
looked over and they said that's a specs
right early release jr. he's our junior
junior don't pay jr. no mind
oh look at junior alright well junior
comes out in these trees and juniors not
gonna home runs out the park
alright and and we know Nintendo with
their little strategies as far as
bleeding it and making it for us forcing
people to believe that there's a need to
purchase the system but not having it
available and if you got one you felt
like he was a chosen few and you saw
your friend with it and you needed it
and you understand so this this this
false affair that they put out for
everybody to make sure that they get a
switch they insuring the fact that when
switches are available everybody
purchases all right
so foster man they made that now in
doing this they positioned their self in
a way that they weren't threatening to
Microsoft and they weren't threatening
to Stoney and now they have Sony and
Microsoft making games doing cross play
sharing networks and my question to you
guys is did Nintendo pull the ultimate
hustle by having
guys work for them to boost up their
system and will they overtake these guys
in ensuring that Microsoft is playing
cross-play with these guys and using
their their systems and Sony's making
games for them like who would've thought
in this weird bizarro world that's what
happened did y'all see this coming
because I did mmm cause what do you feel
about Lord kings switch for less Theory
the necessary as for Nintendo alike you
know kind of put in a little bit of
switches out there I know I know all
these companies pretty much do the same
[ __ ] like I feel like that's like the
same concept what marks off was trying
to do with their little Scorpio edition
you know have a limited quantity to get
people you know everywhere so not
everywhere but and your whole
advertising slogan was um or bye-bye
well they like it'll be gone forever
some [ __ ] like that something will be
gone forever you know and I feel like
all these companies pretty much do all
that [ __ ] but as for you know Nintendo
finesse and Sony to put games on their
platform I don't know about that I guess
they're seeing the success of Nintendo
and they wanna jump work cuz Sony
themselves said that they're not trying
to do another handheld again right so
why not why not um get some money or put
some games on the platform and I don't
know I don't I didn't really read too
much about that story like what was that
all about like Sony's gonna be
publishing games or some [ __ ] but as a
different song you're supposed to deal
with that whole situation so basically
yes only they open up a label called
unties basically uh literally untying
them from the Sony name and it's just
it's under Sony Music Entertainment so
they're gonna be publishing indie games
on PC and what they said quote unquote
other platforms but they already
confirmed at least one
I think it's called tiny metal um to
come to the switch the first one is a
big deal too much I mean from what I've
seen in the games the games I mean it
they seem like they're 3d action games
so they're not you know pixel art 2d
side-scrolling games like they they were
some horsepower so we'll see the quality
over all these games that are coming out
but it's just it to me it's just a
little funny that they're doing that
it's kind of sneaking in the back though
after they said that they need them
anymore but again like King said yeah
you see the power this which you see
what the switch is doing it makes no
sense you have to try to find some way
to get a piece of that pie you know and
and as for a Microsoft one in cross-play
seems like marks off has been pretty
friendly overall ever since they started
getting your ass whooped you know what
I'm saying cross play with Playstation
for how long you know what I'm saying so
I'm doing it with Nintendo I don't
really see it and um I think Microsoft
is just trying to be as friendly as
possible you know I'm trying to say this
to look just to present them present
themselves as consumer friendly as
possible I think that's what Microsoft
remedies Lord um not at ik what do you
feel about this whole switch from this
theory that Lord Keynes got going on you
think they finessing out here to try to
act like they wasn't threatened and
sneak up like what do you think I think
it's just out of theory I understand you
know somebody just sees first off I
think they're only gonna really put
stuff that that was on the that was on
the Vita you know the next few years I
do the Veda I think they're probably
gonna pour that all those resources into
one studio just popping out games for
the switch there's good on portable
mm-hmm okay now I fear this interesting
i'ma jump in real quick
I mean yeah hey little kids go because
um it's kind of interesting like when
the switch was announced like you know
let's be honest like I mean for the most
part the industry kind of they roll
their eyes until they got the
information it was kind of like okay
we'll see you know kind of thing and as
at the Offutt isaac starting to come
through and you know you start to get an
idea of what this thing was it was like
this hybrid console and the be honest
you look awful like that's what sold me
when I first saw that initial commercial
who's I seen that you could play it
anywhere I was like oh it's pretty much
a portable to handle you know yeah you
call it a home console you want you know
but it's a tablet you know right from
the beginning I I thought it was gonna
be a success
sweetie what Nintendo what Nintendo
handheld is not really pop it you know
I'm saying and the fact that you know I
heard Nintendo combined your handheld
Studios with their like home console
studios or some [ __ ] like that so I kind
of seen that like this thing is gonna be
popping well you know some people
predicted I handheld gaming is dead you
know what I'm saying by Nintendo made a
I like how some people are medical made
a poll or I didn't get a poll of like
where do you play your switch in the
most place like the most um choice
elected was at home I play my switch
mostly at home to fight and how I play
my switch at home was told if I don't
know about yard oh boy like my switches
are off dock most of the time everything
one time when I'm live she was I pretty
much played at home like I'm portable
and I feel like a lot of people play
like this - oh absolutely for me yeah
there's nothing it's more in fact
imported bility is a huge selling point
if people don't see that the huge size
yeah for me I I work out um it's looming
on my workplace right next to me you
know I'm saying
whenever I get any type of down to the
point where it's like I look forward to
going to the doctor's office I look
forward to it today cool yeah since I
put my headphones exactly that is huge
and to be able to mimic console
experiences you know pretty much with
not much loss and you're still on the go
with it was just amazing so you know
back to LA Kings question with the whole
finesse thing I do think there's some
level of like people underestimated it
right so then it comes out it's now a
success and I just think - Lord Kings
point there is some interesting this
what the timing of like the Sony
announcement now you know with them
that's to deal with minecraft being you
know I'm saying across play with rocket
League you know I'm saying now I'm not
saying that
maybe Microsoft looking at it like maybe
not it's not benefiting them like you
know completely but I do feel that that
helps Nintendo like that to me we're
learning more content for me big big a
player base you know as far as doing one
shot of the triggerman in the chat you
don't see what you saw on as far as the
UM the cross play but well the way I
look at it as far as the reason why I
think it's a benefit is because when you
have a game and ultimately like the
community has going on from it that
online Lobby shrinks so if you have more
people and a fool to play from your game
to me it just last longer so I think
ultimately that's one of the benefits of
it and I've seen him in chat asking
about like what do you feel about it but
um yeah I'm not just think I think it's
one of the things that's like slyly
Nintendo's kind of getting to eat off
for that I don't think that that
forward-thinking to kind of purposely do
it but the fact is like they kind of
slyly eaten off of it because it just
makes sense that the form factor of the
system the way the system is is
perceived to be used is it in direct
competition for the most part of what
the big two are doing so everything me I
think they rigged the big tool realizing
that there's no reason not to get in bed
with them in different ways it just
doesn't make sense
I think the reason what Sony is that are
like look we we have an infrastructure
in our company that makes games for for
you know handhelds it's useless not to
use them now since we have an outlet for
four I for handheld we might not own
that a handheld but at least we can make
some money off the stuff we used to do
on the Vita but not have to produce the
hardware yep and I feel Microsoft as a
software that that you will see Spartan
assault live for me you're gonna see
Spartan assault on that system you're
gonna see Halo Wars probably one I don't
think - I doubt it but Microsoft is
gonna produce games for that system that
system is gonna get to the point where
I'm noticing it and I'm saying it and
I'm saying they dare position yourself
there we did
threatening friends God change your
clothes they do care listen I'm telling
you these guys is pulling the ultimate
finesse sorry gonna do some old HD
remake uh some old games and put it on a
joint they don't like you listen you
could eat over here it's okay I like
Nintendo plays their cars right dhansika
have in your hands like one of the
greatest portable systems I've ever it
depends on a manager you know what
content he brings way you know the
updates what people want update your
property like the fart when I hold my
switch it feels amazing you know I'm
saying it looks great the biggest
difference between the switch now you
besides portability is the Wii gamepad
felt awkward in yeah yeah you know it
was a little bit of a toy this one feels
like like it looks good it looks like a
premium product it was designed to be to
be seamless I know I know game an attic
played Zelda breath for a while on it
you played Zelda and like how does the
game look on the display just looks I
don't know to you by me looks like oh my
god like I to be like it's just pretty
amazing to see such a quality like you
know looking game on such a small
form-factor like that and that's the
sell of it I think once people I'm
actually playing plain and try it out
see how good the games actually look on
the display people or understand you
want to jump in yeah it's funny that he
mentioned like the updates and stuff cuz
that the new update just came out the
4.0 update that brings the switch
further into the 21st century we got you
yeah USB headset oh you report oh my
goodness thank you
you know like it's like it's like
everything that you know let's say that
in gaming you have like divisions like
you know you got the gaming division the
features division besides the gaming
division III I feel like I hear it's the
Tindall man they're trying way too we
all know they suck like we all know they
suck you features we all know they suck
online we all know they suck so that's
why I like we kind of treat I understand
look we have higher standards when for
Xbox and placing there's no denying it
we have higher standards even you know
when like party chests aren't working or
the [ __ ] Xbox Live people are going
crazy because we have higher standard
for Nintendo you know people I guess we
do give them a pass cuz for so long like
they just been behind so when they
finally do some like like right or that
should be in there from the gate and
people are excited and happy you know
I'm saying
pretty much pretty much you know I'm
saying like that's why it's such a like
such a big deal disputes and stuff like
you know the the lineup on the switch
it's like look like you know I get that
people like certain games on the switch
but you know I am kind of a you know a
closet
you know achievement person I like
achieve it's on the down
like I don't really tell a whole lot of
people that if there's a game on the
Xbox its meatball on the Xbox for
achievements oh and and I totally
understand that logic I mean the way I
look at it is yeah I mean what I love it
I mean I heard there was a rumor that
they could be working on it song I
didn't working on it apparently we'll
see if they come do I hope they come
yeah that would be dope if they included
that coffee with the ohm the only last
subscription and really go on but no
wider charging for this ship goes like
this voiced I can't send messages you
shouldn't be charging they just added
the feature that if you get a text
message you don't interrupt I did to me
like honestly people on Twitter you know
bland rude doctors you're like oh I
don't know bland you said it but I have
seen dr. Dre it's like oh third party
supports coming oh boy okay you got
doomed that came out like two years ago
well it was last year and you may know
spy coming out maybe six months later
like if you're honest you bought a
Nintendo switch expecting all major
third party oh we already know it's
hardware limitations it can't play every
single next gen experience absolutely
people look at me weird when I say I
only bought it for first parties like I
have no interest nothing wrong with that
I do my playstation right now it is like
for you right now there's nothing
grabbing you into like those big
releases and you know out of season all
that stuff so I get it you know I
totally get it for you it's just one of
those things like I have to see some
gameplay on a not game play but I had to
see how like I think I see bro well it's
it's not that I'm hating on artists it's
that what I played at e3 was cool but it
was like nothing grabbing like they
didn't get me hyped for the game or
anything like that you know I think a
lot of it's an
like if you like I guess have a biggest
three like Mario 64 and stuff like that
if you really play those type of games
like I go understand like you don't care
for them
it's like I was telling a you know lore
Cognito like I played mario 64 mario
Tasya mario artists eve our galaxy and
such up but I ain't never be any of
those games yeah so yeah so it's really
not your cup of tea second I prefer the
platforming ones like the 2d platforming
one um the opposite and like the 2d
weather okay to me I like the 3d ones
better and that's fine like people wait
a week to play Assassin's Creed and wolf
inside it's all good it's like as we go
wrap up the switch finesse tap it Lord
addict you gotta talk about uh what's
going on EA announced that their clothes
and visual Studios down I'm pretty sure
it's already closed by now and uh you
know they're the you know I know a lot
of people for those of you that they
made a other dead space and I know a lot
of people and they made the infamous you
know the game that probably destroyed
their company which was hard lined I
don't care what Lord even says that game
was trashed
but you know and a lot of people ro
upset over the the Star Wars thing and I
get that but at the same time I'm like
dude am I the only one that's getting a
little like tired of the Star Wars games
like I'm tired of hearing about it I'm
tired of B it everywhere how much do you
really play-doh like think about it like
you're saying there's a lot of Star Wars
games but like besides like the Lego
ball should I we've been seen in the
years like I don't think it's
necessarily games I think it's Star Wars
right in general okay I see yeah I mean
ever ever since about the games it's
like every year I see hype for another
movie
then I hear game getting announced and
height for another movie then I its
square Enix is making games I'm just
like yo I think Square Enix making
Marvel games actually it was it was so
quiet it was so quiet after the the
second trilogy for a long time and then
once Disney took over you know they were
gonna milk that money back
exactly Disney's gonna he's gonna kill
you for the next 30 years quick what was
the last Star Wars games to the drop was
it like Force Unleashed kind of crap
release before the Battlefront it was oh
no that one got cancelled the 13th might
be for some least I can't think of
anything else I'm not a Star Wars guy
either like that I'll be honest but it's
but the second one since I got a chance
to play it I thought it looked great I
thought a play better on Xbox when I
played I think it was mainly server
issues but man it was atrocious when I
played it I'll drop the address in the
in the call you out on your bluff Brad
but gaming at it aren't you a huge
Dragon Ball fan no I mean I couldn't
tell you the last game I bought Dragon
Ball xenoverse that's all okay and
before that I could hear that's for
years but I don't mind I love it though
you know
comes out it's just I'm getting tired of
the Star Wars hype is all like but
that's I mean that Star Wars I your your
opinions notwithstanding there a lot of
people really love Star Wars and it
that's not going away anytime soon so I
think more than more than anything else
the the scary part about this and and
the sad part about this is visceral
going away right yeah the fact this role
I think I was more upset with dead space
and yeah I get the absolutely is death
but this rule is one of those one of
those Studios that do the 360 era even
before Xbox and GameCube era they made
those the lord of the ring games and
action games that were pretty cool and
they really came into their own with
dead space and for me death base holds a
special place for me because when res
Evo went straight up action death phases
what kind of carried that that kind of a
survival horror torch forward like
because res evil wasn't it like five and
six that was not what I was looking for
rebel
so I mean it's sad that they that
they're going the scary part about it is
this like you take an Amy Hennig
directed third-person story driven
action game aka an uncharted game
directed by a mechanic in a Star Wars
universe and you decide after like three
and a half four years to take it out
back and shoot it in the head oh my god
that's a big deal it didn't like I was
more frustrated with 13 13 because I
actually saw some yeah look like you
can't really care too much you isn't you
can't compare this to like scalebound or
somewhere we've seen in like three three
conferences
the role then the shits like it's kind
of kondal it's kind of like Microsoft
when they announced that they had a what
was the Halo game that they announced
that they may go blocks or like two days
later started apologizing for canceled
like why are you apologizing for
canceling for forecast like a game you
never announced this is the thing with
this game though this game was in
development
long before Amy henyk came on so the
game wasn't depressed one point it was
two years in and then amy hanen came on
so you have to assume that a lot of that
was redone once she came on in terms of
story and everybody so now you're
looking like from a business standpoint
I see why they did it because now you're
looking at a game that isn't coming out
maybe until 2019 and it's a
single-player game that you're not gonna
get a lot of replay out of so and that's
assuming it so it's a great game we
don't even know she put a little boxes
into a box in like The Last of Us right
in the last of a story mode it's not
they did the multiplayer yeah mm-hmm so
it's different cuz this was gonna be a
straight of just a story based game I'm
sure they could have figured out a way
to do well trust me there's dead bowel
they gotta do is is it a Warner Brothers
know how do we do this because I would
never have expected loot box as a
channel yeah I think the scariest thing
about this is that this is anybody if
there's anybody who has the capital to
have a game like this keep going it's
them Activision for them to just
eliminate it and pivot and be like no
this is not where we're going because
we're not gonna make enough money on it
it's scary to think what smaller
publishers and developers are gonna do
yeah yeah it's funny you said let me
jump in real quick song on your point
especially with the omen you know
obviously with the single-player games
you know obviously there's a lot of talk
on the streets that you know those are
dying and everything's kind of going as
games as a server so there's a lot of
obviously is a lot of concern
with the community and the other thing
about it which really personally for me
I felt the way about it was the a me
anything because she was just like what
she just kicked off for Naughty Dog
so again she gets this job with Star
Wars the Star Wars game and then 4-10
shout out their own suit with the forum
podcast guys cuz they were kind of
getting in depth with this too was that
um you know she was actually hesitant to
jump on board with this like maybe it's
internal beef like I feel like this
internal struggle or something going on
that made that because like weird never
know the real story Levin oh yeah we'll
never know all right look but back to my
point with that what the henyk thing was
just like you know I feel for her
because of the same time like she left
that situation she came Lee situation
she was hesitant about jumping on this
situation and then boom now they out is
she's out of a job
yours they like I think she has a story
to tell Mike so y'all need to call up
Amy ain't like y'all have an issues it's
single player games still employed by EA
she's just not working still well they
haven't said they haven't said what her
role is gonna be moving forward if she's
gonna decide to stay or not
that's awesome you'll probably hear
we'll probably hear something in the
future though yeah all I'm saying is
Microsoft need to be jumping on when
these studios get broken down what they
first thought yeah but like at this
point like for Microsoft to build up
studios and know everyone always says
that like the Vice but it seems like
Mark stuff that's not what they're
interested in doing right let's be real
here Microsoft right now they want those
those games that play for a couple years
constantly on the top 10 they what they
own for honor they want they own citizen
rainbows succeeds that was the that's
model they could they talk about is
those games because Ubisoft is like
hitting go after gold with service place
games due to the thing will you be
solved those that they're also taking
risks I mean the rabbits the rabbits and
that's one thing that's is Ubisoft is
like valued not even close to what
actively exactly exactly I and then not
even value that at half of what you know
Activision is or on EA is and they're
willing to take that risk and then you
have these bigger companies that like
now I'm not like like just just just
just think of that for a second man who
ever like any other kind of you know I
did see here that I did see the
interview where the X comma Korea the
XCOM director said that uh because they
were talking about Mario Mario Plus
rabbits and he was pretty much like they
Loki stole your formula how you feel
about that he's like I didn't know that
was on the table if I knew that I'd been
talking about it sindelle years ago and
the funny thing is like yummy soft
definitely took a wrist like think about
the concept baton behind Mario Plus
rabbit it's like whatever
pitch that I do deserves an award it's
like we're going to put Mario with your
rabbit franchise it was like say what
like what are you doing yeah I mean it
was it was something that was unheard of
at the time and it took a risk and it
actually paid off so it is interesting
to see the approaches you know I'm
saying with all these companies like
Microsoft seem to take a a safer
approach but you know as far as the
visceral thing itches I said I never
want to see studios close you know so as
much as yeah much people complain about
what's going on in the industry I know
there's a lot of talk with
microtransactions little boxes I'm not
saying it these are the reasons to keep
Studios alive but ultimately what I
don't like seeing is when we get
announcements like the visceral thing
and it's just like to him and these are
the people that make I don't even like
especially in console wars like people
using it as like it's like talking point
it's like aw Lionhead Studios shut down
Microsoft of Microsoft in trouble it's
like dude that's a lot of jobs that you
try to use for you
you know your own agenda yeah absolutely
these people got laughs they got job you
know I mean even tools like car great I
mean even though was a success like
wasn't it like they won't verge themself
just to make that game almost out of the
home mortgage in house just gotta be
careful with the rhetoric of you know
when the when these things happen cuz I
mean you as we see the results so do we
get any more things on this visceral
things anymore no we good quickly I
think another reason the game could have
gone also is that third person action
over the shoulder they already have that
in battlefront now I have a single
player which is essentially that um and
they would be stepping on each other's
toes and like I said before there's no
guarantee the amy hanen gaben was gonna
be great
it might have not been run snuff so you
know it could be a number of reasons why
they decided to pivot the fact that they
were so forthcoming about everything
that they were doing is kind of weird to
like I nobody ever tells you that much
stuff about what happened with the game
that was really strange why they did
that I don't know maybe because the Luke
Cage drama they wanted to avoid as much
of that as possible and like just kind
of be forthcoming but that was that was
strange to me yeah I think it's like
Kobe said this is in the the border
front of a face
I used to work for Naughty Dog things
going on that I have to tell about that
for the rest of Jenny so um actually
this one I'm just kind of kind of break
my heart to talk about Lord so I'm just
gonna get into my tablet so it's with a
great sadness represent my topic to the
round team what this feeling for some
time but it's Lord God knew y'all know I
gotta keep it true at the roundtable
near I hold in my heart for the over
casualization to be a hardcore game
let's get to it we go get to it right
now good points good points
you know so Exhibit A what are you gonna
talk about that
yes need to play a base so reports have
come out that the destiny to player base
has dropped by over 2 million users
since loans a week yeah we see your
shadow wasn't you one of them if we
compare this to destiny one a month at
the September which was a 2014 when they
had 3.2 million concurrent now brand
mind I was a brand new franchise yeah
I'm saying that Activision they didn't
explain it well remember like we didn't
really know what destiny 1 was right and
then now that people know what destiny 2
is and you know seems to be a more
polished and for the most part you know
review decently game you know it's been
a steady steadily drop ever since you
know saying the last two couple days I'm
lonely lost over 400,000 players so
right now they went from three point
five to one point five exhibit a Exhibit
B
Activision destiny to physical game
sales fell more than 50 percent from the
original in its first month so that's
the physical sales decline one is 50%
for September sent from the September
2014 release if that's new one you know
I'm saying you got analysts like pack
attack and these guys out there saying
that the sales were underwhelming now
the argument could be said that you know
during this time you know during that
time that the 360 and the ps3 wear out
the user base but since then you know
the Xbox one in the PlayStation 4 user
base have grown just as much right and
digital sales from what they were speak
was single maybe people bought a digital
you know that kind of thing
you know analysts are saying you know
right now I big be like in the mid 20s
percent me maybe mid 30s for destiny too
so that still doesn't account for the
50% loss then we have Exhibit C that's
the tooth in game now Kofi I know you're
not a destiny to guy like that yeah but
um talk about one of the big things in
the community was the endgame right
people want to get on them raids you
know I'm saying they want to do they
trials the iron banner and all this
other stuff which is kind of perceived
for you know once you finish the base
game this is got the hardcore endgame
activity is supposed to have replay
value and since testing 2 has been
launched there's a big uproar in the
community if you look at reddit right
now coffee with you know it is licked
people are going in on Bungie saying
that everything is casualized on power
doesn't even matter like when you when
you beat a raid like over like what
would happen is you would get gear that
would actually be specific to the rate
that help you with the encounter right
so all these things that made it stand
out for the hardcore are now all gone
everyone's kinda even playing level
power level does it matter you know I'm
saying so this is a big thing that yeah
like and then the other the other point
which we talked about last week on the
LP was just about
you know they had all these good systems
they had strike specific loot they had
scoring and strikes they had all these
things that towards the end of the
Destiny one ERA and then like post
taking king is what they really started
to improve destiny you know I'm saying
so pretty much kind of like what you
said on your last podcast kind of like
you were gonna get into the taken king
but then you know you were kind of like
too far behind but you did hear that
they did a lot of good things right yeah
all these good things that they added
Govi are not invested so there's a big
that's exactly what not because people
are saying that these features should
have been there on launch and that come
December or come with the next DLC watch
they magically appear you know yeah the
last the last point you know with this
over the tessellations ation thing is
you know obviously they just had a
twitch calm stream Bungie was out there
then talking about seasons so this is
the hole right there
yeah they're talking about they add in
you know every set in the clan progress
to zero they add in a couple of more
hardcore features they're doing things
with in-game content and rewards to try
to fix that so they do seem to seeing
that the community is very upset and
they want to do something so I bring
this to the Lord and I'm actually gonna
be starting with coffee first because
he's not the destiny right and I'm
pretty sure you were thinking about PC
but you may not even pick it up so based
on all this information right of what
you gonna like tell me why you are not
interested right now at this point of
even stepping into that destiny okay
first you know I was waiting for the PC
version because I actually played the
beta and I actually liked it I thought
the game played really well on PC and
looked a really good but main reason I'm
not picking it up on PC I don't even
know about this [ __ ] that you were
saying I'm just finding about about it
today main reason I'm not picking it up
does this mean this month is pac-man you
know this must be Wolfenstein this has
origins Super Mario Odyssey soft parts
according to some Lords you know those
game
this motors impact whatsoever no that
was a little crazy first of all on and
that's neat just seems like one of those
games that you know you got a seat you
got some time a lot of timing right so
yeah I feel like oh I like I felt like I
was gonna pick it up later
wow you're explaining the game seems
like you know I might wait for the you
know 2.0 you know destiny to try my damn
game it Oh we'll see I'll fill of food
though I was gonna say as far as like
the um I was gonna say took the Lord
Alex point he was talking about like how
like all these games being out right and
like one thing that Destiny's always
been strong as far as the player base
and maintaining it so not a coffee you
made a good point I found all these
games you know on route these games
technically are not here yet right and
the player base is already dwindling
right exactly so you would imagine that
would happen once the games are already
out right like the Assassin's Creed's
you know all the Mario's to stuff like
that you think okay Destin's gonna lose
some player base all these games then
you got November you got you know call
do all this stuff you know how
concerning is that part to you yeah one
knows one um what's the call October
27th come around we'll see if the
numbers drop even more how you're
explaining it it seems like more of the
same but like they took away what the
core audience really enjoyed about right
the first game absolutely absolutely
shout out the ink amir for plugging
bethesda fallout 4 player police
maintained for at least five minutes
shout out to you anchor for you had to
plug the ultimate crooks the older
recruit so bring it to the lord's unless
let's go around table let's get our lost
solve you represent the casual base
you've been playing
and then play alright this what what do
you feel what do you stay with this I
think in terms of the content stuff I
get I think the hard core has to
understand that you guys devour this
game not play you devour this control
troll practice it's it's a little on a
little unfair to be calling them out for
not having sufficient content when you
guys the the rabid wing in which you
guys play this game I just got to back
you up one second softer I hate to cut
you not about the conscious about the
casualisation well I'm just you know
you're totally honest with destiny
players or fiends we stuck this way more
than the average gamer
we're crackheads you are absolutely
right all I'm to the vote is as far as
the systems that are in place for
in-game content and just also explain
about the UM that the player base stuff
I want to know get you your feedback
player base stuff to me I think it's
just by the fact that you've opened the
game up to more people by casual izing
some of the system's the same casual way
they came in to play the game now and
didn't play it last time they're
casually moving away and just playing
other things it's just one of those
things like when you have when you when
you add to your base people who who are
more generally casual about their games
they're not gonna stick to it regardless
so you're gonna have that that a larger
portion they it's gonna use naturally
gonna have a larger portion people
walking away from it until the next big
drop comes it's just it's just the
numbers are bigger because the numbers
around it or bigger I don't care what
they say about the physical sales I
think the digital sales are strong I
think we're gonna see more of that on PC
I think generally they're there were
more people playing the game then we're
playing the first one at the same point
so I think it's just a matter of the
type of people playing the game are more
willing to walk away from it that that's
that's right in regards to that in terms
of like the system's again I don't have
the point of reference to that and play
the first one as much um like I said
last weekend the week before I think I
we're just gonna see an evolution of the
game where little by little they start
rewarding more of the hardcore by adding
different things I heard something about
Christie's nightfalls of the prestige
rating where they started adding like
different objectives or something like
that I heard they were talking about
this in the the twitchcon presentation
where they were just gonna little by
little they're adding more reasons for
the hardcore to play more and more and I
think that's just gonna be an evolution
of the game they realize that they they
over casual eyes it to get more people
in the door at the beginning no it might
be that way it I don't know I will it be
too late for you will you go will you
not go back to it because yeah I
consider you hardcore so would you not
go back to it and I think the hardcore
will come back to it you address the
issues to be honest with you they don't
address the raids I don't see me putting
too much time into in the destiny you
can ask look hard needle I'm a huge
right guy and if they don't know the
rest the rate issues I don't see me
playing the story for that like the so
to see what happens in the jumping
straight off and not talking about
Martin Martin the glitch stuff in the
range like what is it that's bothering
you about the race it's just the
animatic right now the fact that you
know they try to cash lies into you
because they don't want to like Kofi
would you agree you know cutting off
loot for like okay in destiny they have
a you know a hard rain and a normal raid
and I think they said what like only
like 15% of destiny like the entire
install base completed a rate right they
didn't want to they when you get too
hard rate it's even worse it's like 3%
mm-hmm and on baby zeros in the
buildings with a shot of Mount you know
this gear that's in these two code
that's in these two these these two
events they don't want to isolate it
from everyone so I you know I get that I
get that but my thing is like look if
you don't want to you know grind
figure out to do the strikes I mean do
the right go do strikes all day I don't
care it's like when it comes to destiny
they always had that base and then they
had the hard core
destiny to the base is the hard core and
that's the issue you know if you wanted
to just a mess on a point it was good
it's just the point that is I think it's
a change of philosophy at Bungie home
when it comes to this game in particular
because it was classism before it was
like they looked at your gear when you
walk they said let me expect you don't
worry about his poops you know you don't
understand their efforts like it does
study if you didn't have light there's a
gun called the Gjallarhorn and for a lot
of encounters that demanded the guy
Lorne
so like I've literally been in parties
where someone's like can you help me at
the raid he's like you had the Gallo
he's like no he's like you got homework
come back when you have it exactly see
meal or addict trust me when we say we
do these raids we do these raids for
real I listen like I said I've read
people through these prestigious this
week and I'm telling them how to attack
a room and how to position if you ever
play with me I'm gonna tell you how to
get past things and how to do it
correctly
um because we thought it out and trust
me I did a million times but in these
raids we strategize going in now we get
the mechanics down on the easy raid and
we wait for the hard way but we also get
to geared the gear is supposed to help
you make the raid easier but the
mechanics of the rain that's what always
been in destiny so all the rate gears
always had those properties or unique
properties and right now the problem is
everything in these raids are cosmetic
there's nothing that gives an advantage
there's nothing done it like that's
that's the me issue beginning so the
over casualization of it is meant to
bring in these casual place like Lord
sovereigns say
these players don't have the attention
span to stay with your game once they
achieve light level three or five that
they could get without even doing a raid
they are no longer inclined to stick
around shadow of war comes out hey hey
I'm over here carpet comes out hey I'm
over here now the base that's still
sitting here kicking screaming a
fighting I know this is gonna happen we
already paid for the premium edition so
we're gonna get all seasons right you
already waiting for the DLC to drop so
you're stuck here regardless there's
some guys that aren't they're gonna buy
each one that comes out if by the next
DLC they don't fix this mechanic with
these raids because the next raid is
gonna be there then that raid isn't as
far as class-specific
when they drop items and drop gear and
it doesn't enhance the raid for you
there's no sense in going into the raids
tracking down gear and and you know
items because it doesn't help you defeat
the raid so why would you run back into
the raid unless it's just spawn with
your friends it goes back to the
symptoms guys had yeah it goes back to
the point you guys have had for a while
saying that why are you taking away
things that were standards in the first
game it doesn't make sense that a lot of
these things are just God and this is
what things okay I guess I'll finish I
gotcha me one I mean one theory I might
have is like obviously we know that this
game is not on last gen could it be that
by starting it sort of from the ground
up they couldn't implement this stuff
from the beginning and have the time to
finish implementing all this stuff like
let's get let's go okay I don't know if
it's a technical thing or like like King
said it's a it's a different philosophy
and they're approaching it differently
and then now piecemealing everything
back according to how people complain
like you complain about something
they're gonna fix it if you don't
complain about it they don't even be
well the player basis is dwindling so
they're gonna have to do something but I
got lost their own building for this
topic this authorizes a channel 5 clean
destiny to member who I'm staying in the
building one written iron law so let's
deal in that problem respect
lord zero I've seen you kind of
dissipate into the nether realm you've
been in the dark that hood gets lead
much lately talk to me what's your state
of things what do you feel about this
all my compensation of destiny to talk
about we gotta get you back together
they go they go yeah cool hold buddy's
feet to the fire because I need to
improve
let's get facts that's as much as the
first one doing this that's fact
right six weeks later shout-out to Lord
ran he put out a you know I want to say
today or yesterday Clara babe I still
buy whoever you have said well great
yeah you know a spot just if you finally
come back yeah your body again yeah we
think you can hear you say nice boy you
know it's classic example of a company
that's trying to bring in a new player
base and not really paying attention to
you know its core and then at the end of
the day you know what is okay look I get
the initial you know they they want to
get out the gate as quick as possible
but the problem with that is you know if
you look at it a year two years down the
line you know if you piss off your core
enough they're not coming back and these
we're going to be the people the core
gonna be the people the hardcore will be
the people that that keep your game
alive through the next couple of years
like you I don't know how the
sovereign's gonna be but you know people
like me people like you know everyone in
this podcast but Kofi and sovereign
they're the ones that's going to be
buying the expansions they're the ones
that's gonna be playing the expansions
and you know even if Laura Kofi got
destiny to on PC there's a good shape
because he plays so many games he's like
one of the only people I know this be
Noah so you know actually and I'm hooked
I'm hooked that's oh I'm gonna play all
the experiences and stuff like that
again I don't I'm not gonna say that I'm
gonna be hardcore like you guys that are
you're going in prestige rage and like
you know them like the back of your
hands like that that can't be me like
because of my god it'll just never be me
because I know like once you know next
year Red Dead comes out like everything
else falls to the waste I was something
about everything's gonna fall inside
Lord Sami you did an eyeful bro I've
you've come such a long way
oh you back you back baby that was good
there we go how much made it through
[Laughter]
what I'm saying is destiny too has a
soul as much as the first one this is a
fact this is no arguing that right Iran
put out Lord Ram put a video out the
player base has dropped all 78% that's
huge that is bad and it's a six weeks
out before any big games come out right
thank you that's my point
no he's supposed to reign supreme and
yes and and the most striking and
shocking thing about this to me is even
though I didn't like to a minute back in
the old IOP days when destiny had
usual playerbase the fans that would
come back and keep concurrent you know
playing was the PvP fan base right yes
they're the lowest number right now TVs
by far hired and this is factual this is
backed up by destiny tracker and other
sources this is true right yeah people
do not like crucible people do not like
the new four before V matte versus
instead of the 66 people don't like the
way their trials and I have been are
right now there's Larry she's a token
thing let's be honest I know Laura
caveats there's nothing like it but the
token thing is the stupid casual flag
flag so we understand we come from
lovers which I respect
I respect him greatly and the thing is
my issue what does that say to thing and
me how about we've been back and forth
on this plenty of times through Twitter
messenger all gun stuff and my thing is
I respect where he's coming from and I
don't want destiny to do anything that
takes away from him or Lord's house fun
in any kind of way what I expected from
destiny and I feel like it was fair was
for them to include those names
there's things into the base destiny to
that they had an endgame doesn't he want
and I know some technical issues but
destiny ones
excuse was that and was holding them
back right so they couldn't do as much
as they want to but now that we have
these new systems they're not doing as
much as they did yeah yeah there's two
arguments counteract one another and and
this is simple things look like if you
go in and you compare to vault space now
to the end game vault space and destiny
one we actually don't have a have as
much volt space yeah thanks for that's a
good point and yeah and I just want to
get you don't put coffee to sleep with
all this destiny talk
what it is both is that we as the
hardcore place obviously we represent
the hawk we play this game a lot and
that one of the things just to see the
regression of features like what kind of
like what Lord Lord r0 saying is one of
the things that we've a lot of the
player base is calling our Bungie and
thinking it may be a finesse because
there's no real reason for these
features that existed to actually not no
longer be in the newer iteration of the
game if I'm saying move on right so it's
like you know it's like what sports
games come out like they they'll add new
features and stuff and then generally
those features get added like saying you
know a new man or whatever the next
iteration will have those features for
the most part that has done this right
now this recent absolutely absolutely
oh [ __ ] we got we got lower Chi box with
a building test to repot zero here we go
[Music]
cope if you want to take off our
complete football so we can't go I'm
gonna say is that I do agree you guys in
terms that they need to do more at the
end game but there's a button alright
big is that with the token system
everything that's currently done right
now you can have all that other stuff
but one thing and I was asking for and
they're actually doing with the iron
banner now now that you're gonna be able
to buy your gear using the token alright
wow you buy your gear using the tokens
and the legendary shards while also get
being able to do the roll if you want
what what you what you're referencing is
the latest Bungie twitch calm stream
where they add about talking about the
changes that they're gonna make coming
and they're gonna do the seasons thing
so you're taught your thing now you talk
about the hope of what what they listen
in to the community and trying to
implement those things and make changes
this early game is that what you're
referencing yes I agree with you guys in
terms that they need to do more with
endgame but the thing is
current token system it allows them to
levity to do to the way that they could
do both
I like the talking system mainly so you
don't have to go to the tower you can go
play two to three hours and get all
those or rewards and then go in and cash
them there's less downtime when you went
back and forth because that was my issue
with destiny one that's the one who had
engrams inside the inventory which is
the eight up at your inventory so you
know you would have to the the tower and
when necessary grinders back of a blue a
perfect balance for that for those
typing is that you play 45 minutes to an
hour and then you go back and caching
your stuff at the town it name there
needs to be a good balance with that so
those so that way you're able you have
that urge to go on and on if you're
going back to the tower and plus you
have to go through those low times which
also I appreciate that they eliminated
the lowest times the whole okay fair
enough enough research it back I agree
with what you guys are saying although I
do feel it's a bit early and I do think
everyone is gonna my points to you Laura
car box and I'm gonna don't extend it
too long yeah I feel what you're going
here when you're going as custody the
only thing we have to now acknowledge
that is with these systems that you know
a lot of the casuals do like the casuals
have finished a game they've moved on
and also this player base is now
dropping see that now that's a different
reflection of the community for whatever
reason they're done with the game
they're not playing and people are
falling off like wildfire so that's
where we now have to take it serious
with maybe some of these systems that
they casual eyes now are coming back to
bite them because those things kept
people hooked that chase for the loop
that chase for the granite or leaving we
cannot go to be put on the current
system couldn't be put on the current
system as it the question is why isn't
it why was it let me say this real quick
features know
I agree attic finished off okay all I
just want to finish this whole statement
with this everyone in this podcast isn't
playing destiny right now there's a
problem you know what it's like is like
this right you see that Gran Turismo
sport that they just put out right now
and I think I think they put that sport
in the end to tell you you're not
getting everything bro you already
whether is there anything that's missing
from the game yes just a general
question is there anything that's
missing now that you guys think could be
monetized because we talked about this
when the game first came out and the
whole bright engram thing and and the
shader thing and I said it yes they're
gonna try to find a way to monetize I
think it already is with the fact that
there's a $15.00 DLC in December there
you go I wouldn't be surprised at all
that stuff that we that we complain and
bitching about now it's gonna come out
we're too smart to at that point so
right now that's why again because you
remember man I mean we going back into
this loot crate talk but the fact of the
matter is that destiny is a $60 game
we're like a season pass type thing
beyond that and beyond what they try to
do with the bright engrams and the
silver and stuff like that there is no
further monetization and
Hill down footballs look that you know
Tommy I apologize I was gonna get into
your Activision thing we're gonna hit
that next week we already know what we
feel about that with the multi player
finesse matchmaking we're going if we go
hit that back for you next week no doubt
we gotta yeah because we're we're going
to that it'll be all back and we got
coach we go in this thing up real soon
but you're first of all shout out to
look holes either coming through
absolutely learn how pleasure man like
huge thing you know say it's great to
have you at the roundtable hopefully you
come back so definitely want to shout
you out and um want to telephone people
where they can find you and then a press
start podcast it was a pleasure I'm you
can find me up press start Kofi that's
my channel name and I have a weekly
podcasts called press start podcast um
I'll try and have some you know hit me
up on Twitter I'll just have some of
y'all on man I'm always looking for new
Guinness if you haven't been on hit me
much appreciate much appreciate it cause
a little awkward sometimes Alex got you
there man go watch that Alex out to all
them real quick Kofi before we go I
wanted to don't drop that last um LP
poll question right now because it was
actually inspired by you in pocket first
off I guess here we go alright it is the
new our people if serious
now when I say serious ethical or sexual
allegations are discovered against a
publisher or developer of your favorite
video game franchise mmm-hmm will this
honestly stop you from purchasing and
supporting the product the answer the
proposal America baby save or be no this
will not stop me from buying a game keep
it simple look don't look to me to be a
role model to me
is good or not give you information we
don't put it up yeah let's be honest we
gave jobs and like Red Dead you know a
dev you know I sexually assaulted a
person which is absolutely horrible
ah I ain't gonna punish myself and not
play together now that like the whole
freaking team like the lead of Naughty
Dog came out was races saying you know
everyone on that podcast Azad still no
and I appreciate that because they on
see there being a hundred percent honest
of shallow nobody's that's the question
these are the choices please rock that
vote I'm gonna put that up on the IOP
Twitter polls heart please hit it hard
when you go up let me get these outros
problems we get out in a football on
deck Lord addict we're gonna find people
find you follow me on twitter @avaya APN
me on youtube gaming addict and xbox and
playstation room to kill whenever I am
on PlayStation and steam gaming app no
doubt Lord sovereign people find you
first of all shout to Kofi thank you for
coming through man appreciate it
Lord people can find me on PSN and Xbox
Live at BX sovereign and Lord Savio P on
Twitter look out for some Mario Odyssey
impressions I guess from all of us next
week don't be in there no doubt lord
King way to the fabric found you
Facebook Instagram Twitter Oh
PSN yeah shout out to hip-hop gamer if
you didn't check out the video podcast
that we did
on Monday laughter played it was
fantastic um like like I've learned this
is the Buddhist way I went in with bad
intentions he went in with enlightenment
and enlightenment one I got smoked like
a cigarette I'm here to say listen I
know anchor your heart is broken baby
Oh a man is another day baby if I could
get up walk around you could too listen
yes Ashley Florentine can come back from
something like that anyway he showed
honestly and Grayson winning and also he
wanted to show his uh to keep the
viewership up like we lost nine people
and I hope it wasn't with the talk that
we took destiny down with but in keeping
his viewership up he learned a lesson
and he had to do it a certain way so I'm
glad he got on and talk about why he did
what he did now he did maybe we don't
agree with it but he came through to
give his side and I love whose man is
doing that so uh shout out to Kofi my
man you're like I really really mess
with your podcast so the fact that
messing with your podcast cause look
like me don't put me onto all these
podcasts out in these streets um you up
there with my man Bret there's something
here and I really like it stuff and I
really appreciate the fact that you came
through bro
yeah I also wanna shout out the two laws
that came in um saying one of the og
Lords obviously Lord zero shout out with
the four people find you you can find me
anywhere on Xbox facebook Messenger
where wherever on their zero out peace
we love you that's what we talk about
you know always hold the feet to the
fire wouldn't the honesty and of course
Lloyd kind by some the man willing to
debate at any time of day stop doing
Kofi definitely youngji the Genesis love
you know I always got to respect that
anyway the people can find me on Twitter
at Lord Cavett sue and also on xbox live
Lord kebabs
as well thanks guys for listening
absolutely no doubt actually smoke out
here like I said we spend that gaming
realness on the IOP and I tell you what
you wanna hear
but what you need to hear once again
shout out to press star Kofi and whole
team for coming through please hit that
like subscribe all you guys on the inner
circle Network media outlets YouTube
iTunes Google Play and of course that
amazing tick gene page here we got our
multi first brothers up next you know
saying on Monday with anchorman undead
Mike the truth Fame all them guys please
listen to them and we had if you just
missed it you know podcast super
potshots was on up there the tech
podcast excuse me was up there they have
leader had Rand on last night they were
talking some really cool topics Neil
Jeff Renee we've got burning down suited
to that episode as crazy tickly out here
we trying to do stuff and make the
context on that note we are out of here